هو واحد من مختصي الذكاء الاصطناعي
المشهورين في العالم والاشهر الماضيه
قداها او قضاها بحذر النواب والناس من
المخاطر المرتبطه فيه مثله مثل كثار من
المختصين في المجال ومن كم يوم كان له
حديث مع وكاله فرانس وجدت فيها التحذيرات
والمخاوفين
عامين معي
جاري مثل ما سمعتوا ذكر بمخاطر وحذر لكن
جاري مو من اللي وقعوا على البيان الجماعي
اللي تكلمنا عنه من كم يوم واللي حذر من
خطر انقراض البشريه اللي ممكن يتسبب في
الذكاء الاصطناعي جاري ماركوس ورغم كل
تحذيراته من الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن لما
ننسال عن الانقراض قال هذه مخاوف مبالغ
فيها
وبما ان الذكاء الاصطناعي ففي فيديو منتشر
على المنصات حول العالم وعامل قلق وبلبله
مع انه طوله ما بيتجوز كم ثانيه
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفتم في الفيديو رابط باستعليا
قربوا من شكل وحركات البشر مو عادي لون
الجلد الشعر الرمشه كله مو معقول قد ايش
شكله حقيقي والناس بدات تتداول الفيديو
وتعلق على حقيقه شكله او قديش حقيقي شكله
وقديش هذا الموضوع بشكل عام مرعب وتخيلوا
عاد علشان يزيدوا الرعب بيكون من بين
المعلقين الان ماسك اللي شاف الفيديو
واكتفى بالتعليق بعلامه تعجب الحقيقه
الواحد على فيديو زياده محتاج علامات تعجب
كثيره مو وحده بس يعني صراحه على فكره هذا
مو الفيديو الوحيد فمن كم يوم في بريطانيا
كان في معرض روبوتات
روبوتات ههه والحاضرين انصدموا من رابط
محاكي للبشر فعليا يخوف هذا
الرابط اللي شفتوه الان اسمه اميكا وهو
معروف انه من اكثر الروبوتات العالم تقدما
وتطورا بيكلموه في المعرض سالوه عن الذكاء
الاصطناعي وحذرهم منه